there is a bad rumor but no the biggest
thing it's a rumor oh I look like a wimp
last week so I'm gonna grind like tooth
this week you know I won't be there very
Lois what yeah I mean story I could tell
[Music]
what is up and welcome back to Sims and
Lefko headed into week 4 week 3 is in
the books and Monday night I thought oh
no the end of Ryan Fitzpatrick has comes
second half almost wins the game where
are you on the Ryan Fitzpatrick it's
over he's still going I'm over talking
about it on a weekly basis already I
know that like we were like every week
he had a rough first half against the
desperate Steeler team but battled back
and made some big-time team I definitely
still his team what's more annoying
about the Monday Night Football game is
that game should have been over about a
quarter before it was but we are not
allowed to blow in the ear of
quarterbacks anymore and those are
penalties but you're a quarterback Chris
I don't care I'm old school they need to
hit them hit them hard I don't want
anyone to hit Ryan Fitzpatrick after I
saw him doing this oh your unadulterated
joy this is after the Mike Evans
touchdown
now Fitzpatrick he did get sacked a few
times last night we got to see his sack
face and we had everyone reach out and
boy did we get a lot of years of their
quarterbacks getting sacked in Week
three and we want to take people into
the minds of the quarterbacks as they
get sacked so you go first
ah Eli I looked like a wimp last week so
I'm gonna grind my teeth this week I can
take a shot from the gut to JJ Watt ah
tough eli means this week alex smith
McCallie bro look at how my hands riding
the wave of this football man super
loose super chill super cool do your
favorite quarterback oh my favorite
quarterback hi I'm Aaron Rodgers so I've
been carrying this team for 10 years let
me just carry the Redskins along with me
I hope this guy throws me down like a
rag doll and then they won't call it but
they'll call it on my guy later on Clay
Matthews when he makes a perfect form
tackle all right I got Andrew Luck
dearest Rebecca I ask you to remember
me not for this sack but for my career
as a whole signing off
your captain Andrew Luck oh look who it
is oh look who it is it in the shut two
peppers right in the old gutter oh oh
please Julius don't hit me in the spleen
it's already losing blood at this point
hit me a little lower than the spleen it
won't hurt I'm still tough and losing
blood and dying on the field that I'm
playing now I'm gosh I might have to
retire early and go work with some idiot
named left go one point wait so you're
telling me that the game that we chose
for your sex I am traveling spleen and
look I said that's after you lost your
sparta ball I didn't I mean it's insane
being destructed as we're watching it
right there it's bleeding internally but
just shows you how tough I am look
leaves in blood I don't even make a
Wimpy face I'm just like losing blood
dying doesn't matter see that's why
you're okay with the roughing the passer
you're able to look at your stuff you're
a true self scout yeah I'm really proud
of thank you for me but I am I think we
need to do some self scouting or more
analysis that's what separates us as
analysts were okay admitting when we're
wrong
Jared golf yeah you were very you were
questioning his abilities questioning
his talent even our fans upset with you
keep the Rams out of your mouth Gurley
was a one-hit-wonder STFU all that stuff
but a lot of Rams fans have come at you
and I criticism of golf
okay self scout yourself yeah well I
mean golf I think what I said early on
is what he was the the fact that I would
do I want to say he's a system
quarterback early on he was the number
one pick of the draft and he had to be
massaged a little bit his first year or
two okay
how about now the hood right now yes I
mean we're seeing a new Jared Goff we're
seeing a guy that is not actually
managing the offense or mcveigh's making
things so easy for him what I've seen in
the first three games from Jared Goff is
actually a guy that I'm going wow
getting out of the pocket making
big-time throws in the run Wow throwing
101 mile-per-hour fastball as I'm
painting the corner into a tight window
to a receiver or wow a bomb throw down
the field right on the money so those
are things that I didn't see I thought
the offense and the talent around him
early on was more carrying him than the
other way around but we're seeing
guy that's coming into his own right in
front of us and I got no problem with
that I'm not gonna STFU but fu - Brendan
Mecca McIntosh I hear that you have a
self Scout for me oh this is gonna be
more fun
have you seen left goes locks lately
let's sell scout that why because
they're horrible what's so wrong with
them euro at eight so the last two weeks
I'm oh and eight it's my job to pick
games right it's their job to decide
what to do with my picks if they would
have bet against me all four games in a
100 dollar par let you know how much
money they have right nearly fifteen
hundred dollars if they did it for two
weeks you know how much money they'd
have nearly $25,000 I'm still thinking
about Oh an eight pack kidding yeah well
guess what Michelangelo didn't paint the
Sistine Chapel because he thought he was
more of a sculptor huh I thought I was a
winner picker I'm not I'm a left go
loser Locker okay so use my information
correctly and maybe you would have made
some money this is not a me issue it's
of them issue sin oh I got you're such a
diva wide receiver that's disgusting
he's open every play coach throw it to
him that's never his fault I have a
story from another diva where I receive
her little Chad Johnson where he claims
that he almost beat up Ray Lewis almost
Yeah right
almost good luck Chad you know I'm
almost beat up Ray Lewis but yeah I mean
a story I could tell I like going to
almost almost is the key phrase Oh
nobody because listen ray and I are very
good friends to me - he won our so we're
playing the Ravens were in Baltimore
gray and I talked before the game we did
our ritual that we always rejoice meet
after 50 and we say a short prayer in
the game at some point it was a slant
that was thrown too high he hit me in
the safety eat me at the same time in
his sandwich yeah my helmet went flying
right and I jumped up and I ran
everybody like a goose gonna fight I
just had one gonna hit him during the
game but I'm gonna get thrown out right
but where could I catch ray in the
locker room after the game after the
game
what so what do I do I put on my tie
team because all my clothes are tight
right tie up mushrooms real tight and I
go towards the Ravens locker room
as IDI where rape and I just want to
talk man ray he went out the back door
and you know already heading to the car
so I go out to the parking lot and he
pulling off and I'm running at the race
car yeah sure I'll know and everything
I'm gonna at the rate car I'm like yo
yeah and I know he could see me in the
rear view mirror
cuz at that time you know I had a little
size on me I don't think that beef you
know I can I'm a box in our box yeah you
know and I think he understood it knows
about my hand and therefore he didn't
want to get showing up and it really
savory giving a little more time to get
away get to his car yeah right you see
how close you were to get your ass beat
by Ochocinco almost ya chat almost all
right we have three-time Pro Bowler
DeMarco Murray in the house DiMarco we
want to play a game that we call debt
chart I'm gonna give you three names and
a scenario and you have to tell me which
one you're going to start which one is
the backup and which one is in street
clothes okay so the first scenario is
this a baby is falling out of a window
which of these running backs do you
trust the most to catch it start back up
healthy scratch Darren Sproles David
Johnson Le'Veon Bell hopefully it's not
my baby but uh I always say Sproles okay
because he's a little softer he's a
smaller guy who and he won't hurt the
baby when he catches the baby soft
landing um I would say David Johnson is
my I don't trust love you on bail
catching my baby
he may be rapping the door something
mentally maybe else worth alright your
uber didn't show up
you need someone reliable to pick you up
who do you call Jason Witten Delanie
Walker Zach Ertz
mmm that's a good choice there hey dad's
a reliable do y'all reliable yeah I mean
I got to go my man wet and then wit is
always on time he's never late yeah I'm
every time he's told me he'll he'll be
somewhere he's there I would say Zach
Ertz Delaney is a little different
Delaney Delaney maybe he is you know I
had to talk to this girl boys you know
the when he has his boys like yeah man I
got caught up I got no you know he has
his voice I can't be easily if so you
got Witten there we're stars of stars
Earth's as the backup and then Delaney
is the street clothes yeah yeah and you
know witness I like Johnny perfect yeah
over there you may give me a lesson
yeah but it's always a lesson that you
can take you know and always you know
maybe a little aspirin but it's
something that you can take you know and
use it in your life
guys take coaching well yeah but I've
been worried about with witness be like
he's just a wimpy driver and we don't
get anywhere in time it's like everybody
know go one more for you music DeMarco
Murray start been street clothes who
would you like to control the aux cord
at a house party
Fletcher Cox Marcus Mariota Dez Bryant
why can't we just say radio like what do
we go what the hell's that awkward
because you wanna you want to have your
own music bib yes I have my own z100 how
come so what can we say DJ who can be
the DJ because the kid is going we're
cancelling our Yoda right now okay I'm
just gonna say I don't know you don't
know that what kind of music would
Marcus Mariota you know you know he
likes the island music which was great
you know but unless you know you like
autumn so Wednesday practice I'm not in
the mood then I hear this song right
right yeah yeah I would say I would say
Dez Dez will probably have the Ox chord
there's no he'll mix it up and he's able
to take some advice off I say hey Dez
put this song on and he'd be like so
you're telling us that is coachable this
is very coachable rumor that's out there
it's a bad rumor but no the biggest
thing it's a rumor oh yeah pleasure
likewise definitely was fun it was fun
this is D'Angelo Holly you're watching
Tim's and left go hello and welcome back
to Sims and Lefko we're not all fun
sometimes were investigation and we have
something brewing in New England you're
very well aware of all their scandals
deflategate Spygate mired in controversy
the latest is this the end of the
Patriots dynasty for a little bit more
insight i've
brought in our NFL informant we have of
course had to cast him in shadow we are
modulating your voice sir you're a true
patriot thank you so much for joining us
no problem of course of course I want to
establish a little bit of your
credentials here you did work with the
Patriots and you were able to witness
coach Bill Belichick on a regular basis
I did I got to see the inner workings of
the New England Patriots how they
approach things on a daily basis and
certainly observed the greatest NFL head
coach in the history of the sport you've
seen hit the way he starts his day
you've seen the way that he goes about
his day what kind of a man is Bill
Belichick well he is just an absolute
grinder that's what he is he is detailed
focused on a daily basis it never
changes you see those news conferences
that's not an act that's who he is would
you say that Coach Belichick had any
vices well everybody has their vices but
the one that was concerning to me was
the saltwater taffy excuse me yes
saltwater taffy
yes Bill Belichick is a sucker for
saltwater taffy specifically from a very
well known place at the Jersey Shore
called Shrivers is this drivers in Ocean
City New Jersey exactly how would he
obtained this saltwater taffy god I
don't know I'm not sure how he obtains
it I'm not sure if somebody ships it to
him or whoever it may be but always had
a big bucket of Shrivers saltwater taffy
how often would you see him consuming
this saltwater taffy there would be
times where I'd see one or two in his
hand
maybe you feel with his pocket where
he'd be walking around but the amount
consumed on a daily basis hard for me to
tell sir would you say that you noticed
more of the salt water taffy consumption
beginning middle end of the season
certainly the beginning of the season
almost a training camp snack oak tree so
you're saying that earlier in the year
he is consumed with sugar
he has tantalized by treats he is worn
down by the wonderous snacks of the
Jersey Shore
that possibly not your words my words
mr. informant he could possibly see so
consumed with confectioner sugar that
he's unable to process a game plan
October through fear oh so smooth and as
the bucket of taffy goes down the wins
pile up fret not Patriots fans the taffy
will soon be gone
mr. informant you are a patriot you are
an absolute prized possession of the
Sims and left Kosho and I thank you for
your service thank you for having me of
course
I'm blown away he looked me in the eye
and the connection between taffy and
Belichick makes sense to me I don't know
you know who is this guy
I question it I mean put a face to it
that's what I would say come out and say
you're hiding behind what some dark
lighting I don't get that I don't know
if I trust this guy I do a lot hey guys
how you doing Ali here Ali's newsstand I
just wanted to wish you guys the best of
luck moving forward I hope that you guys
make better best than I did last week I
know I fell short but you know I'm still
two for three so if you need any more
picks make sure you come and see me 57th
and Broadway Ali Ali Ali I thought you
had it everyone here at Sims and Lefko
was rooting for you and in came Baker
Mayfield dude
I even had these t-shirts made I'm
really sorry but I got $250 I got
another Thursday night game and I need
another New Yorker to pick my team it's
what we call somebody and left go the
quest to find New York's best random
better continues I'm here with IRA
freehoff you run this joint cook shop
yes
yes but now I'm looking to be the new
Oracle who I tried looking for now was
that a message to sim and was Chris
watch your back Chris so you have quite
the matchup Thursday Night Football a
great game great game Minnesota loses an
embarrassing fashion of Buffalo now they
head to the Rams who was just crushing
the Chargers Rams are favored by six and
a half and that's where I think about
the NFL it's so crazy when you think
you've got it figured out you don't
I definitely as you said the Rams are
unstoppable the Vikings played tear
against the bills but I'm thinking maybe
they were looking ahead they certainly
want to make up for that yes their five
a nose straight up and against the
spread in the last five games against
the Rams we've might have ourselves a
shark and for those reasons I like the
Vikings to keep it close if not win
outright the Vikings plus six and a half
for my page Wow
even though the home team is won every
Thursday Night Football thus far even
though again when you think you've got
it figured out
nope you don't I thought I had you
figured out I'm going against Tyra
because I want to go against Tyra I
don't like IRA I like him but I don't
want to go with him okay and I have
questions about the Vikings match the
Rams I trust the Rams are the best team
in football they're steamrolling
everybody we had questions about the
Vikings going into the Bills game they
lay an egg what's the deal with Everson
Griffin it's Thursday night and they're
the road team I'm going Rams in mcveigh
football wise Vikings interior Oh lines
a little weak
Donald sooo big trouble Oh little China
Sims everyone's question my left cola
yes me too and Owen ate the last two
weeks so it's been well-documented so
this weekend embrace the mush is the
hashtag house or whatever you see my
picks go against it with your bookie
your fantasy team your survivor pool
show me on social that you're taking the
opposite of my bets and hashtag embrace
the mush I hope you go for now this week
thanks bro buddy for Simms peace out
homies I'm left go we will holla holla
holla at you later enjoy the games this
Sunday
how would he procure such saltwater
taffy I don't know what the cure means
so you'll have to explain the - how did
how did he obtain hey what's up homies
thanks for watching subscribe to the BR
YouTube channel
man you're such a millennial also while
you're here we have a lot other videos
check them out and then what time does
our show come out Wednesday 8:00 p.m. be
there or be square
he ruined it it was really close